foreign
[Music]
and I want to
tell a few stories about the DM package
and show recent developments
in a nutshell DM helps when you have
multiple tables in R some call this a
relational data model so we had
computers for sale in the 50s we started
to think about databases in the 60s 1970
at gracot
published a relational model
and this is way before I was born and
still in use today
an example
the points at the right are energy
consumers in Switzerland
stored in rows in the table at the left
and there is a lot of detail in all
those related tables and this looks
scary
with our client we wanted to build a
shiny app that allows filtering across
all those related tables this shows the
shiny up in action
all we had back then was a tool to
visualize the relationships we did not
have tools that made the task less scary
so we went ahead we implemented a
routine that did all those joints and
filters
in like 800 lines of code it worked but
it was tedious it was difficult to
maintain it was error prone
and we thought we can do better than
that
and that's how DM was born
with the m package the filtering logic
was reduced to a variant of this
so from 800 down to 6 and the best thing
is if the data model changes the code
stays the same I call it a success
others call it sxs2
it's amazing
treasure it's Lifesaver thanks Carrick
and sadly
and snails thanks to everybody who filed
issues who contributed
code to the DM package you are awesome
best thing is
we are on Crown in version one
our universe in GitHub as well so if you
want the latest and greatest you may
want to go to our universe
if you don't want to mess up your local
installation click this posit Cloud
button this gives you uh well should I
say our studio cloud
at some participle change
IDE in your browser with everything
installed so you can just test so there
is no excuse to not try it today
right
some people are wary about dependencies
we are not among those people so in fact
the M wouldn't have been possible
without all those great packages
we depend upon without our core without
a tidy verse without igraph thanks Gabor
without well everything thanks
This Is Us
and I always wanted to bring this but
I'm repurposing this today so we're
talking about multiple tables
so which of these tools has a concept of
an active data set right you start a
program you open a file and this is your
data set and you work with it right it
is one car one data set many cars many
data sets we in our we don't have the
active data set that's a good thing
took me a while to realize there's a
difference between data for analysis and
data cleaning data management so for
analysis all we really want is tidy data
rows columns cells with atomic values
everything lined up cleanly ready to put
into our model except there is
duplication in those highlighted Parts
at the left
and we can't have that for data
management we can't have that for data
cleaning this leads to problems further
down the road so if we try a different
approach
wide form this is better there is no
duplication except that those beautiful
column names
make me want to turn this into long form
the first time I see it
so
we want multiple tables we need
often
multiple tables and we want the M
because that's what the m is doing
if you have more than one table the M
makes your life easier
we are in a databases session so many of
you will know about primary keys and
foreign keys this is just to make very
sure we're all on the same page very
briefly the data set we saw in the
previous slides could be decomposed into
two tables
measurements at the left entities at the
right so multiple measurements
correspond to a single entity the
entities have a primary key the ID
column the measurements
have a foreign key also in the ID column
linked to the entities
and in fact this is what a DM object
contains
tables
this could be local data frames
or lazy tables on the database with the
DB player package
maybe Arrow also works but I'm not sure
we need it more on that on the last
slide
we have primary Keys ID and we have
foreign keys that link tables together
that's the DM object
but
do we really need a new package
for two tables for
for five tables even for 10 tables just
wrote before
will it actually make your life easier
will it integrate into your existing
workflows
will it help you in your work and I
believe the answer is yes yes yes and
I'm sure you how so this is
a very new thing a shiny app we have
built and
the team at synchra helped a lot with
that so thanks here for all the support
I
um got when preparing this this is the
adventure Works data set if you're
familiar with that and
that's the shiny Urban action
so if we start from the database we can
with pointing and clicking select the
tables we care about
we can create code
that we can run immediately we can store
it in an R script we can put this into a
function so David here will talk more
about how to
turn this into a real r package but for
us this kind of works
so you run this shiny app once this is
pretty much like the rstudio uh posit
IDE
import assistant
it will give you code that you can reuse
this is just a summary so
selecting tables
gives you code which you can
copy to your console at once
for the data frames use case when you
start with data frames data frames don't
know about primary or foreign keys they
have just rows and columns so we have to
teach
VM what those keys are and we can do
this as well with the shiny app so we're
selecting the tables
we're selecting The Columns that
constitute the primary keys and the
foreign keys and we get an instant
preview
in
the diagram
same here we get the code plus we can
also experiment with colors I find this
very helpful in guiding the eye in a
more complex data model
there is an undo function if we mess up
so and if you're satisfied
the copy to console button will give you
the code for this data model from your
data frames
so that's new that's in the M version
101
and
yeah to sum up works for
databases for tables on the database
versus data frames
try it out
in our Consulting work we are using the
M well you saw the expression whenever
we have more than one table the m is
just the basic thing that that we do we
used it to
help with a shiny app
that handles contracts
so this is a situation where we
have
for a
contract partner in the first stage
contracts at the level of individual
countries and then the second stage we
would pool contracts together
to get an overwatching query for for
this customer and this shows the
database UI that we have contributed
with projects called family quotes and
this maps to this data model that we
have
designed with the DM package and
applied to the database as soon as we're
ready and we could also
continuously update it because the data
model is specified in code
so the first stage is everything that's
orangish at the bottom
and what we can do with the m very
easily
for a specific quote which we identify
with the primary key the quote ID we can
get all the related
data in one swoop with the DM package
loaded locally
update
what we need based on the input from the
shiny app put it back to the database so
this is create read update delete for
you in shiny Made Easy with the DM
package on a complex data model
for data analysis
so this is the NYC flights data we use
it throughout the documentation of the
of the flights of the DM package if we
aggregate the flights table let's say we
Group by origin summarize compute number
of flights per origin airport or let's
say mean
arrival delay
what happens is
um
the result is a table that is
conceptually linked
with the airports table
so this this group I summarize creates
an implicit foreign key
into the airports table because the the
data in the origin column maps to what's
been in the airports and this link is
useful if we want to later bring in
details from airports
or from other related tables maybe not
shown here
how does the DM package make it easy
to
keep track of your keys we have a new
feature
we call it deconstruct reconstruct
you can go from a DM object from a data
model
to individual tables that still know
about their primary and foreign keys I'm
not going to tell you how but we can
talk about it later
we can apply data Transformations on
those Separate Tables with deeply or
tider or whatever works for you and we
can put this back
into a relational data model as a DM
object
a bit of code so the new the empty
construct function
there's nothing except printing code so
from a DM object that has tables
primary keys and foreign Keys it will
give you code that gets you those
Separate Tables
which you then can compute on
so key to equals true is kind of the key
here
the DM Constructor on those objects will
result in an object that still has all
those primary and foreign keys in place
and this also works when we have
analyzed
the data
so here the new table will
contribute one primary key one foreign
key I'm very excited about this feature
we had a similar concept called zooming
before but this of course doesn't
integrate as well with existing
workflows so I think this is a step
towards
helping
adapt the amp to
existing codes so that you could benefit
from the M even if you're not starting
on the Green Field
that's what the resulting game object
looks like
I've had this before
why one data model why just one data
model we can do more
so this is
an example from another project with
another customer
the
nodes the boxes and these diagrams are
whole data models the arrows represent
data transformations
this is a an ETL process extract
transform load
targeting
whole
data model data models datable objects
whole data set going from data set to
data set
giving better guarantees moving to the
right in terms of data quality data
integrity
and so forth
we don't have a specific framework to do
this this is right now all custom this
could be a blog post
but we have a pretty good idea how to
how to do this because there is an inner
and chicken and egg problem here
when populating a database we first need
to create a structure
the tables with the columns and the
relationships
in an empty form before we can fill them
and and how do you know this structure
so the the MP type function helps us
which gives us the Prototype of a
um
DM object meaning
tables and relationships minus the data
which we then can write to the database
and
populate
I want to spend the last
few minutes on a new idea that didn't
make it into the M1
but that that we are also excited about
normalized data has been around for ages
and will stay around at the other end of
the spectrum we have deeply nested data
so when you query a web API typically
what you get is Json deeply nested
and uh somewhere in the middle we have
nested tables
with the tiger package thing of Nest on
Nest pack unpack Arrow has great support
for this in
in their data format and what we can do
in DM today is get from normalized data
from a DM object
two nested tables
to a single nested table and back
more or less losslessly more or less in
all cases we're working on that
but this idea looks very appelling in
particular with the very nice tibly file
package which I think is really
underrated we can go from deeply nested
two nested tables in a controlled way
and the way back to Json is understood
so with all those bits and pieces in
place I hope
very soon to be able to present a way to
seamlessly move between all those
formats so so this all of this becomes
one and perhaps nested tables
are a good middle ground because this
would allow us to go back to one single
table that's just easier than all those
boxes and arrows
we are synchra
the team as I said helped a lot
preparing
uh
the shiny app making sure this this all
works thanks here we're very excited to
be a sponsor here if you have detailed
question or would like to chat or would
like to have one of those cheat sheets
here
they're also new come by
happy to talk or happy to take questions
here thank you
thank you
[Music]